a dijon la cour d'assises de la
côte-d'or a ordonné ce matin une
nouvelle expertise détaillée des poumons
prélevés sur le corps du petit grégory
il s'agit d'apporter des éléments
nouveaux sur les conditions de la mort
de l'enfant
aujourd'hui alors que débute la
quatrième semaine d'audience on va se
pencher sur les écrits du corbeau les
avant cela ce matin la cour a entendu le
témoignage de jean jacques leconte qui
était le procureur de la république au
moment des faits dominique verdeilhan
gibrat gries la sphère ne les avaient
pas réunie depuis de nombreuses années
ce matin dans la salle des témoins ils
se sont retrouvés le juge jean michel
lambert à dijon pour la seconde fois
jean jacques leconte à l'époque il était
procureur de la république à epinal
aujourd'hui il est président de chambre
en guadeloupe les avocats de la partie
civile s'inquiète de savoir ce qu'il a
fait pour protéger bernard laroche
mais pouvoir était limité il n'est pas
de notre compétence de servir de garde
du corps
néanmoins par souci d'humanité j'ai
alerté le préfet de région
il m'avait dit avoir fait le nécessaire
voilà le procureur n'a pas d'états d'âme
pas de regrets il se refuse à porter un
jugement sur l'instruction du juge
lambert le procureur se retranche
derrière l'obligation de réserve comme
un leitmotiv le magistrat répond je fais
peut-être propres de désinvolture mais
je ne me souviens pas à huit jours
d'intervalle les pertes de mémoire
semble être le point commun entre le
procureur le conte et le juge lambert